la page politique de cette édition du 7
8 je reçois ce soir sur le plateau
olivier paréja bonsoir d'europe écologie
les verts yvelines pour parler du sdrif
ce schéma départemental pardon schéma
régional d'aménagement ça va au delà du
département des yvelines avant de tout
vous expliquer que ce soit bien clair
une première question de politique plus
générale qu'il y ait forcément
l'actualité force lamblin l'élue
parisienne écologiste qui a été mise en
examen après le démantèlement d'un
réseau de blanchiment d'argent de la
drogue a finalement démissionné lundi
soir elle a aussi régulariser on l'a
pris aujourd'hui sa situation fiscale
est ce que vous vous attendiez déjà à
cette démission je pense que c'était
quelque chose qui était plutôt
souhaitable histoire qui est absolument
aucun amalgame entre la position
d'europe écologie les verts aussi bien
sur le l'évasion fiscale donc il faut
absolument il fallait que la solide
laisse la séparation soient claires
entre son cas personnel est celui du
parti donc qu'elle ait démissionné c'est
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
après la procédure suivra son cours et à
sa présomption d'innocence par rapport à
la procédure de suivre son cours mais
pour autant est-ce que c'est un coup dur
est ce que vous en parlez également au
sein la des militants écologistes dans
le département par exemple même au delà
les spécialistes les centres et à en
parler ça a été un coup dur ah oui
c'était un coup dur nécessairement
puisqu'on en parle dans la presse que
ces pannes la meilleure image qu'on
puisse donner du parti donc il est temps
que cette affaire soit traitée que
clairement sa responsabilité soit
établie par la justice et puis et que
compass la page c'était le mieux qu'elle
démissionne tout à fait tout à fait pour
effectivement suite plus sereinement
travailler et notamment parlé du sdrif
on va en parler à présent c'est notre
sujet principal ce soir les élus du
conseil régional vont entamer demain
mercredi mercredi et jeudi l'examen de
ce drif le terme est obscur et pourtant
fondateur c'est le schéma directeur de
la région ile-de-france qui définit les
orientations en matière par exemple de
transport ou de logement à quoi
ressemblera l'île de france en 2030 pour
mieux comprendre ce reportage signé de
notre confrère de votv
florian philippe l'île de france en 2030
ce sera plus de 60 nouvelles gares 240
km de métro en plus 70 km de rer
prolongée et autant pour le tramway
améliorer encore les transports en
commun
de france ce sera l'un des objectifs de
jean paul huchon le président de la
région vous allez avoir des
prolongations de lignes de métro et de
tramway qui vont évidemment rapprocher
les franciliens de leur travail ou de
leur logement et puis vous allez avoir
autour des gares véritablement une
urbanisation qui fait que globalement
aucun habitant ne sera plus de deux
minutes d'une gare cette promesse
d'améliorer encore la mobilité c'est
celle du nouveau schéma directeur de la
région ile de france
ce document dessine le visage de l'île
de france d'ici à 2030
à cette date la région comptera
davantage de logements 70 milles seront
construits tous les ans avec 30% de hlm
est une ambition construire autour des
gares pour lutter contre l'étalement
urbain et le gaspillage foncier on a
donc choisi en effet d'être plutôt sur
une ville intense sirkis est pas la
densité pour la densité qui nous
intéresse la densité de qualité c'est à
dire que le francilien de 2,80 puisse
retrouver tout ce dont il a besoin les
espaces de respiration le commerce les
écoles il faudrait pas qu'on construise
et qu'on s'aperçoive pour n'a pas le bon
niveau d'équipement par exemple je crois
que ça doit se faire dans un double
rapport rapport bien sûr région
collectivité mais aussi collectivités et
les franciliens ce qu'ils ont à vivre au
local cette intensité
la majorité régionale entend aussi
encourager la création d'emplois
jean paul huchon table sur une
croissance de 2,5 pour cent pour espérer
créer 28 mille emplois franciliens
supplémentaires chaque année pour parler
de ce drif olivier paréja donc membre du
bureau exécutif d'europe écologie les
verts dans le département des yvelines
60 nouvelles gares 70000 logements
construits tous les ans dont 30 % de
logements sociaux ça va dans le bon sens
pour vous à tout à fait la création de
logement fait partie des objectifs
d'europe écologie et verts
donc c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait satisfaisant et de poursuivre cet
engagement et surtout si il y à du
logement social pour autant vous émettez
des inquiétudes des réserves
est ce que vous craignez c'est un
développement économique trop important
de cette région alors il ya le
développement économique mais il faut
aussi se resituer en 2030
donc le prix du pétrole va
nécessairement continuer à augmenter des
ressources fossiles vont être de plus en
plus rares donc en 2030
il va y avoir un enjeu important qui est
de garder une localisation à ses proches
de l'agriculture et de pouvoir améliorer
par rendre autonome l'île de france qui
aujourd'hui importe plus de 91% de sa
nourriture mais rendre l'île de france
plus autonomes en termes d'agriculture
de proximité donc pour ce faire le fait
de ne pas empiéter dans cette
construction sur les espaces agricoles
est quelque chose qui est également très
important pour nous protéger ces espaces
agricoles pour développer économiquement
cette région
ça va être difficile de concilier bien
falloir trouver des terrains aussi pour
construire alors faire des choix tout à
fait mais la priorité que nous on veut
donner et le fait d'utiliser des
terrains déjà urbanisées donc il y à des
zones d'activités qui sont pas
nécessairement extrêmement utilisé il ya
des friches industrielles les choses
comme ça donc avant d'utiliser des
terres agricoles fertiles comme par
exemple sur le plateau saclay ou dans la
plaine de gonesse l'idée c'est d'abord
de densifier les zones urbaines
existantes identifié privilégier les
constructions d'immeubles de grands
immeubles alors par exemple n'ont pas
nécessairement c'est pas antinomiques
le fait de densifier il reste à
l'intérieur on parle de dents creuses
il reste à l'intérieur des villes encore
des espaces qui sont utilisables 10,11
euros talents spécifiques auxquelles
vous pensez par exemple sur saint
quentin en yvelines sur saint quentin en
yvelines
aujourd'hui l'urbanisation qui est
proposée par le sdrif rajoute des paires
steve d'urbanisation donc là c'est des
pastilles de 25 hectares de
d'urbanisation prioritaires dont il y en
a quelques unes qui sont à l'intérieur
de l'agglomération telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui entre montigné
trappe par exemple sur voisins sont
gagnants ferrée par exemple mois dernier
leur a besoin ce secteur là c'est exact
auquel vous pensez
par contre ceux sur lequel nous nous
sommes pas d'accord c'est par exemple
les terrains de la minière donc les
terrains qui sont entre bucs et
guyancourt qui sont aujourd'hui des
terres agricoles d'exploiter donc notre
priorité est de continuer à avoir des
exploitations agricoles de proximité
danser dans ces zones là alors avant
l'été c'était six zones de 25 hectares
on en voit les images de cette zone du
côté de la minière accueilli en cours
qui étaient ouvertes à l'urbanisation
aujourd'hui seulement
zone serait ouverte à l'urbanisation à
c'est déjà un premier pas c'est déjà
c'est déjà un procédé exactement la
position d'europe écologie les verts est
assez clair il n'y a pas besoin
billancourt a déjà perdu énormément de
terres agricoles au cours des dernières
années
donc il n'ya pas nécessairement besoin
de continuer sur ces terres qui sont en
continuité du reste du plateau de saclay
et qui sont des terres qui sont
extrêmement fertile donc il n'y a pas
nécessité à les urbanistes
elles ont parlé de ces zones du côté de
saint quentin en yvelines du côté de
versailles le camp de satory également
est l'objet de vos attentions
on pourrait densifier regagné
effectivement pour le tout à fait là là
c'est sûr de la zone qui est déjà
urbanisées c'est pas de des zones
agricoles aujourd'hui donc la ja ja pas
nécessairement de problème à urbaniser
le besoin de logements sociaux est
évident le sdrif éléments fondateurs
pour une région qui sera étudiée dans
quelques jours à la région c'est un
schéma particulièrement important parce
que au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est le
schéma de 98 de 1998 qui s'applique donc
il y avait eu il y avait eu un incident
rif en 2008 mais qui a été qui n'a
jamais été appliqué en raison de la loi
du grand paris et du projet du grand
paris qui étaient incompatibles
donc le dry faire des carabines complet
aujourd'hui entre les urbanisations
possible les prévisions de développement
c'est pour ça que le fait d'avoir un ce
bref 2012 ou 13 puisque le tank que
toute la procédure se déroule samedi
sera adoptée qu'en fin 2013 sera
nécessairement un progrès pour la région
ce sera un long processus que le cet
examen du sdrif discussions pendant deux
jours au conseil régional 400
amendements déposés 40 par europe
ecologie les verts est ensuite enquête
auprès des collectivités enquête
publique aussi pour une adoption fin
2013 finalement le calendrier presque
assez serré au delà des discussions qui
vont avoir lieu à la région vous allez
rester attentif des improvisations
participer aux enquêtes publiques
également quelle sera la position
d'europe écologie les verts dans les
prochains mois il y aura plusieurs
étapes il ya la participation enquête
publique bien entendu et ensuite la
participation aux débats qui existera
autour des révisions dpu puisque le le
sdrif s'appliquera au plan local
d'urbanisme différentes communes et donc
au moment où la commune décidera
d'urbaniser ou pas urbaniser une zone on
aura de nouveau la possibilité de
s'exprimer
le front de gauche qui demandent que cet
examen l'adoption du sdrif soit soit
reporté vous partagez cet avis c'est un
document extrêmement compliqué
effectivement
400 amendements je ne sais pas si les
conseillers régionaux vont arriver en
deux jours à les traiter tous mais ils
méritent d'être traités et que chaque
cas soit soient étudiées comme le cas de
la minière dont on parlait précédemment
je vais également donné la position du
groupe ump sans que la réalisation du
grand paris ce schéma pour l'ump devient
caduque l'ump qui regrette aussi que
jean paul huchon impose 30 % de
logements sociaux là où la loi
aujourd'hui on préconise 25% le groupe
ump qui estime qu'il ya un déséquilibre
entre l'est et l'ouest de la région
ile-de-france l'est et en plus favorisés
en termes de développement économique
puisqu'on parle de ce grand paris
justement quelle est votre position sur
ce super métro ce métro qui doit
traverser le plateau de saclay alors la
position d'europe écologie les verts est
assez claire sur le métro
l'idée c'est de deux plutôt que
d'inventer des nouvelles infrastructures
de transport qui vont être coûteuse sur
lesquels on ne sait même pas si on a le
budget pour les faire la priorité est
d'améliorer l'existant donc nous nous
sommes beaucoup plus favorable au fait
de remettre en service et d'améliorer la
tangentielle le sud c'est-à-dire la
liaison du rer c qui existe aujourd'hui
entre juvisy et versailles qu'on
pourrait enfin juvisy massive versailles
qu'on pourrait prolonger par exemple
jusqu'à saint quentin en yvelines qui
permettrait une desserte sur des zones
qui existe sur une ligne qui existent
déjà ou le développement du transport en
commun en site protégé sur le plateau de
saclay qui est un projet qui existe
depuis des années peut-être vingt ou
trente ans donc nous sommes plutôt
favorable à développer ce genre
d'infrastructure d'améliorer l'existant
de mettre une troisième voie sur la
liaison vers rambouillet par exemple
plutôt que de développer une nouvelle
infrastructure et dans la commission du
débat public à l'occasion du du métro
sur le plateau de saclay il a bien été
remarqué que l'urbanisation actuelle ne
justifie pas un métro
donc si l'idée c'est de construire le
métro pour autour des gars continuez à
urbaniser sur l'emprise des terres
agricoles
aujourd'hui sur le plateau de saclay
c'est nécessairement pas le schéma que
nous nous préconisons qui nous freine
qui n'ont pas encore assuré en plus
d'intérêt pour ces y ait l'idée c'est
vraiment de favoriser les besoins
des franciliens avant de développer
l'infrastructure pour de nouvelles
nouvelles constructions nouveau projet
sans financement d'un à question
dernière thématique que j'aimerais
aborder avec vous c'est le développement
du nucléaire le gouvernement a décidé de
fermer la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim alors ça nous éloigne des
yvelines et c'est en alsace ce sera
d'ici la fin de l'année 2016 pour autant
se pose la question des délais
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire évoque un
démantèlement qui pourrait prendre entre
20 et 25 ans des délais qui sont
importants ou 2016 ça semble pas
finalement pour demain la fermeture de
fessenheim pour autant il faut la fermer
mais même pour arriver à maintenir
fessenheim en état de fonctionner sans
danger pour enfin pour toute la france
enfin pour tout les gens habitant autour
il va falloir continuer à investir des
millions pour maintenir en état
cette centrale nucléaire donc même la
question de 2016 pourrait être posée est
ce que ça vaut le coup d'investir autant
pour de toute façon ferme et en 2016
donc peut-être qu'on pourrait fermer
plus tôt et réinvestir cet argent pour
autre chose et améliorer la filière de
démantèlement qui va mener c est une
nécessité et qui peut être une
reconversion très importante pour tous
les gens qui travaillent aujourd'hui
dans le nucléaire
faut-il freiner le développement du
nucléaire c'est la question que nous
avons posée aujourd'hui dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines et puis vous
pourrez réagir pour conclure juste après
l'instant non tant qu'on n'a pas trouvé
d énergie remplaçable ont la garde
on va pas retourner au charbon oui si on
tourne à d'autres solutions
ce n'a pas solution plus valable formule
garder c'est ce qu'on a c'est comme les
femmes
on sait pas ce qu'on paie oui parce que
ça devient dangereux maintenant et on a
toujours vécu jusqu'à début du siècle
avec une énergie qui était propre et on
n'a jamais eu de problèmes maintenant
que l'énergie nucléaire a fait dévier
des catastrophes et des désastres
il vaut mieux vaut mieux revenir à
l'ancien temps françois paquet a
tellement de problèmes non
dangerosité est de toute façon drapage
choix pourrait y aura plus de pétrole
faudra bien faire autrement oui parce
que au niveau du recyclage je pense que
ça ne m en déterminant pour recycler
mais trouver des énergies alternatives
moins chères que nucléaire actuellement
je pense pas donc je pense que c'est un
vaste débat pour nos enfants
il fera trouver des alternatives
concernant l'énergie nucléaire
parce que je trouve que je trouve qu'il
ya trop de risques
après ce qui s'est passé à des fuites je
pense qu'il ya pas mal de risques
pour l'instant je pense pas et a donné
que les autres qu'on s'appelle énergies
ne sont pas au point pour l'instant que
soit l'éolien ou le photovoltaïque
voilà pour ces réactions olivier paréja
vous aurez le mot de la fin faut-il
freiner le développement du nucléaire
tout à fait vous parliez tout à l'heure
de dans la séquence précédente de la
conférence de négawatt à magny les
hameaux
il y à de nombreuses collectifs
associations qui ont proposé des plans
alternatifs donc le fait qu' on puisse à
terme pas demain mais dans 20 à 30 ans
se passer du nucléaire ça se prépare
aujourd'hui donc il faut y penser et
décroître progressivement aussi bien la
consommation c'est l'isolation des
logements c'est des choses de ce type là
est progressivement développé des
énergies alternatives
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
commentés notamment ceux drif dont nous
parlions longuement au cours de cette
séquence merci à vous si le rappel des
titres à présent les sujets que nous
avons abordé ce 23 octobre elle les
conseillers régionaux on en parlait il
ya quelques instants sont invités à se
pencher dès ce mercredi sur l'étude du
sdrif le schéma directeur de la région
ile de france
un document essentiel pour définir les
orientations en matière par exemple de
logement ou de transports dans la région
d'ici à 2030 le siac gère le réseau de
l'assainissement de la courance englobe
notamment les communes de maurepas et de
coignières des travaux de rénovation
sont en cours pour remplacer les plus
anciennes canalisations qui date d'une
cinquantaine d'années une cérémonie a
lieu tous les jours à 18h30 à paris
devant l'arc de triomphe en toute
discrétion l'allumage de la flamme du
soldat inconnu à des jeunes de montigné
deux voisins
bretons ne viennent d'y participer le
club de gymnastique rythmique de
maurepas et l'encours a tenu à bien
figurer à l'occasion des derniers
championnats départementaux c'était le
premier rendez-vous de la saison et vous
avez vu les images de la victoire de
manu marin dans le critérium seniors
c'est la fin de ce set 8 je vous
retrouve demain mercredi nous serons
consacreront une large partie de
l'émission à l'avant première de star 80
la nouvelle comédie de thomas langmann
le producteur de the artist les acteurs
seront à l'ugc de montigny le bretonneux
ce mardi soir à 20h à nous allons à leur
rencontre les interviews seront à suivre
dès demain à 18 heures seront présents
notamment richard anconina ou encore
jean luc lahaye peter et sloane et les
images toute cette vedette des années 80
que vous entendrez en interview dans le
7 8 dès demain soir 7 8 édition spéciale
star 80 c'est la fin de cette édition du
7 8 prochaines diffusions 19h 22h30 et
minuit l'internet pour revoir tous nos
reportages et plus les réseaux sociaux
aussi pour les commenter excellente
soirée sur tv fils
communiqué